and now what is life like for brit's at
the age of 70 a new survey by a
nationwide building society gives an
insight sought to find out just that
well according to their report the
average 70 year old spends 11 days a
month socializing twenty percent lists a
Harry Potter film as one of their
favorites and many seventeen-year-olds
listen to pop music as much as they do
classical and three in ten who were
surveyed said they are more active than
they were in their 50s for joining us
now in the studio is the oldest Britain
to climb Mount Everest Explorer and
writer and saran I'll find I do have to
point out you are talking about this but
you're not sort of your average 70 year
old you've done much more than most
people will have done in their 70s well
I do qualified ten years ago I had a
massive heart attack double bypass sort
of pre-diabetic State cancer so I've had
one or two of the sort of introductions
to proper old age and I have found that
after 65 that's on average that I have
to train much harder to keep going on
the expedition's than I used to so
because life is very busy to spend 25
minutes every morning doing fitness and
stretch which I never used to have to do
is a pain in the neck literally a pain
in the neck thank you finally is this
survey finding that the 70 year olds are
more active than they they ever been
most of them said they were more active
than they were in their 50s perhaps even
younger ya know that the nationwide
report makes it quite clear that
statistically they have checked on 2000
old people and got honest answers and
the honest answers are quite surprising
and I think people like my wife who is
quite a lot younger and my daughter is
10 think of people like me is totally
decrepit this report would indicate that
that's not the case at all whether it
used to be or not I don't know but now
there are amazing signs of bubbly youth
in 70 year olds and therefore presumably
80 year olds too it's very obviously the
way things are marketed now
you know that's a specific age group
that people market to mean just looking
at adverts with Helen Mirren on
advertising face cream because we're
still worth it i think is that is the
strap line on that advertising and
obviously 70 year olds want to buy
things like face cream and want to
socialize 11 days a month the want to
still look nice that's right and then
there's the argument about the color
gray whether you know whether you're
male or female you should be stopping it
gang gray III don't know it's a mixed
subject but definitely this report makes
out that we the oldies are not nearly as
old as the young folk thank you 70s and
new 60 or 50 55 I mean is it partly to
do with the fact that perhaps order
people aren't as compartmentalised as
before that they do have a range of
friends of of differing ages that you're
not simply being packed off to the
retirement home at 65 and forgotten yeah
and this is obviously coming what with
the tweeting and the twittering and the
new tubing and all this sort of stuff
which is going on at people who are in
their 80s and they love being able to
get with it and talk to all sorts of
people whether they know them or not and
this year and socializing generally is
getting easier all the time just get it
looking at some of the little details
that have been pulled out a favorite TV
genre is either a drama or documentary
would you fall into that category I
would go for things on TV like 48 hours
I'm afraid that's daddy that is on the
list that makes me there with only fools
and horses in the Two Ronnies and
favorite kind of music amongst the 70
year olds plus tends to be queen ABBA
and the Beatles your family other yes
Beatles obviously but for me Enya is
just brilliant sound simon and garfunkel
pretty good they're all quite relaxing
genes concern you when you're out there
exploring you probably need something to
calm down even going back to some of the
Tom Jones things you know and ya abbas
okay i like now advocate have against a
thumbs up and but some other interesting
things in there and the number of books
that were red nine per year and harry
potter and bizarrely was a big film a
big film and a big book amongst people
over 70 know i can vary
remember in hospital I just had my
fingers off and I got visited by someone
who said have this book and it was a
Socrates cover so I thought how boring
inside the first Harry Potter ah so you
could read it on the train without
looking as if you're reading it that's
right with reading a Harry Potter but
that's fine isn't it to read Harry
Potter have been more ashamed of all now
is it bit more especially in those days
know if you were an oldie you don't read
Harry Potter and you didn't do it right
I loved it exhale do okay whistle
ratifies thank you very calm very much
for coming in to talk to us about all
things and secrets up to 70 somethings
70s Jackie said is the new 1650 40 maybe
could be a very much